it has been 11 days since the nevada
legislature began session
and this year three new latino members
are promising to leave a mark
christian casadas joining us now live
from our newsroom with more
and christian i know you spoke with one
of these new and young leaders
how's she holding up so far well denise
i can tell you we caught up with
freshman democrat assemblywoman cecilia
gonzalez she represents district 16
which is in the central portion of clark
county now she's half thai half mexican
she says it's been very different
because of the pandemic but she's
working
very hard to get things done now on her
agenda is the preservation of land and
water and income protection
for nevada and she stated that her heart
is in the criminal justice system
she's working on a bill which would add
more funds for
prisons and change the public's view on
offenders basically giving them
a second chance all folks are here to
work on issues that are important to
them to make nevada a better place and
so it's kind of just
figuring out what issues can we work on
together to do that i think in this
session we already know we're going to
be seeing
less bills this session because of covid
we know we are in a budget crisis and so
just keeping that at the forefront
well gonzalez is joined by assemblywoman
elaine marsola and senator fabian
donate in the 2000 in the 2021 nevada
legislature and the nevada hispanic
legislative caucus now gonzalez added
that she is a proud member of the lgbtq
community and is hoping to get more
involved in that area unsure
if that will be in a more leadership or
a supportive role
christian casadas 8 news now